foreign
[Music]
executive producer of Minecraft Legends
and today we'd like to give you an
Insider's look at how we're building the
PVP multiplayer experience for the game
Minecraft Legends is a new action
strategy game set in a lush Dynamic
World it introduces epic storytelling
and you can form alliances with new and
familiar Minecraft Mobs to stop the
invading pigments
Minecraft Legends will let you play the
story-driven campaign as an online co-op
experience to get it with your friends
and it will also feature a PVP gameplay
mode where two teams with up to four
players each Works to destroy the
opponent's team space
the game will support cross-platform
play and online matchmaking
in order to create the best possible
experience we partner with Blackbird
interactive to develop the game
and it's been wonderful to see their
commitment and focus on the Minecraft
Universe it's so much fun to be working
with moyang Studios on Minecraft Legends
here at Blackbird interactive we have a
talented team of developers who are
using our background and strategy games
to bring a new and exciting experience
to the Minecraft Universe we're super
excited to share more details about PVP
gameplay
[Music]
all right
there are some really cool features that
make PVP unique first off players share
their army and resources with their team
this means that individual players
aren't able to win on their own they
must cooperate to be successful
communication is really important and
you can sort of really tell the teams
that gel together because they naturally
form roles at the beginning of the game
and as soon as we start you're off
collecting I start building we already
we have our favorite roles but we change
them up
also the world in PvP is procedurally
generated just like it is in campaign
this means that each PVP session is
different than the last
every time you play depending on how the
map is generated where the valleys are
the mountains are where the secrets are
you know where the towers are
in Minecraft Legends the piglets are an
ever-present threat and this includes
PVP the pig ones are on their own side
they're trying to kill both of you at
the same time
so the opposing team is not the only
thing you need to worry about
Beware of the piglands
PVP there's something for everyone
for players who like action they can go
attack the piglets or lay Siege to the
enemy base for players who enjoy
exploration they can search the world to
find resources for their team hidden
treasure chests or Scout the enemy base
Gathering resources to help the team out
that's super important but whenever I
get into a PVP match the first thing I
try to do is to track down the Regal
tiger it's my favorite mob to ride
because it's really fast but it's also
really cute
for players who like building you can
spend your time building defenses and
upgrading your base because soon enough
your enemy will attack and you need to
be ready
so the first thing I do when we start is
everyone runs off I open the map see
where the enemy base is first thing I
build is what we call an upgrade Tower
where it allows you to build upgrades so
I place that at the back away from the
enemy
so I really pride myself in making you
know impenetrable bases
since the goal of PVP is to destroy the
opposing team's base Defending Your Own
base is really important you have to
start with a lot of walls a lot of
towers and some gates after that you can
just add whatever you want freestyle a
little bit
I like to add different layers of walls
so my opponents have to find their way
through to my base almost like a maze
and then once those walls are up I like
to actually hide my ice traps behind
them to catch any guard when it comes
time to finally take out the other team
my favorite strategy is to make a
forward Camp just outside the enemy base
then I get the biggest strongest mobs I
can as fast as I can and start sending
them in
then I can smash Down the Walls take out
their mobs and claim victory
real fun of PVP is creating a strategy
having a game plan deciding how you
think you're going to crush the enemy
and then all of a sudden the hosts tell
you the opposing team just built a
redstone launcher and you're like I
can't do my attack now I've got to like
build an anti-siege Tower which is an
anti-air Tower to stop the Redstone
launches you just have to be constantly
changing your tactics
and sometimes you'll have no idea what
they're doing and then you certainly you
certainly find out very quickly
resources
a while back we had somebody on our Dev
team use a strategy where they built a
bunch of what are called plank Golems
which are archers so they're very weak
but they do a high amount of damage and
he had 40 of them and he just ran
through our base ran around our Tower
and took out our entire Tower with such
a simple strategy and that's why we
still love playing it every day because
every game is different you never know
what's going to happen
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I'm Chris osaki and welcome to turn 10
Studios
the team is hard at work bringing you
the next generation of Forza Motorsports
built from the ground up to take
advantage of the Xbox series consoles
this is the most technically Advanced
racing game ever made today I'm joined
by some of our amazing team members to
show you how we are making it look real
sound real and feel real
this is Forza Motorsport
at launch Forza Motorsport features over
500 cars for you to collect race and
customize with more than 800 unique
upgrades this includes over 100 new to
Motorsport cars the most modern race
cars we've ever featured on our roster
racing is violent it's a battle on the
racetrack the advancements in our
physics model are greater than Forza
Motorsport 5 6 and 7 combined this makes
our Driving Experience more fun and
rewarding in the way the car accelerates
corners and brakes our materials and
shaders are built from the ground up at
higher resolutions and optimized for a
Cutting Edge Ray tracing experience
our paints are sourced using a
spectrophotometer to capture multiple
data points of light behavior on a
Surface this yields a paint model that
has a much more realistic light response
across color metal flake and gloss
damage and dirt buildup is unique to
each car it's now contextually aware and
more localized we simulate paint
thickness chipping and directionality
dirt accumulation is more realistic
Gathering more in the low pressure areas
like recesses and alcoves these
Innovations tell the story of the work
you put into a race and reflects the
marks and Battle Scars of Motorsport
this is our best sounding Forza
Motorsport ever and the first to be
mixed natively for immersive audio
formats like Windows Sonic and Dolby
Atmos to create an immersive soundscape
each audio system has been rebuilt from
the ground up to deliver a new level of
Sonic depth and authenticity for our
players modifying car parts like your
exhaust and turbo change the car sounds
in Forza Motorsport just like it would
in the real world every car now has a
variety of sound possibilities based on
the parts you've installed Hardware
accelerated convolution Reverb
accurately reproduces how sounds in
Forza interact within an acoustic space
dynamically adapting to its surroundings
and creating a realistic and detailed
soundscape
foreign
new features like our regional track
announcer system and improved Tire and
Suspension audio bring a new level of
realism to the game
here for to Motorsport like never before
every tire squeal every engine lap after
life
[Applause]
[Music]
Forza Motorsport launches with 20
environments built from the ground up
for this generation you'll get to race
on iconic fan favorites as well as five
all new to Motorsport locations
including our first in South Africa
kyalami
we capture our environments to an
incredible level of detail when we
reference a track our team comes back
with over three terabytes of highly
detailed photogrammetry and Laser scan
data through the power of the Xbox
series consoles we're able to use this
data to draw up to 10 times more detail
than previous generations you'll see
Lush trees dense grass and overgrowth
vegetation animated track life
physically based lighting and volumetric
fog effects and a fully procedural cloud
system that evolves organically tracks
look alive sound alive and feel alive
with cutting-edge visuals and crowds
consisting of tens of thousands of fully
animated 3D Spectators so you're always
immersed in the pure spectacle of racing
for the first time in Forza Motorsport
fully Dynamic time of day with weather
ensures a constantly evolving Racing
Experience where no two laps ever look
the same meanwhile Dynamic track
temperatures wet driving surfaces and
rubbering in ensure that no two laps
ever played the same
I love the detail our talented team of
artists have built into kailami
fast forward to night and the Vista is
truly breathtaking
you can see the distant light glows of
the city a beautiful visual touch even
the kyalami logo itself creates visual
impact every time you see it thanks to
Ray Trace Global illumination which
simulates how hundreds of thousands of
light rays accumulate color as they
bounce between surfaces we're rendering
all our environments in 4k at 60fps with
real-time Ray tracing on track to create
true to life Reflections on all smooth
mirror and flat glass surfaces
with the incredible detail and rendering
features of our track environments so
Motorsport is truly a generational leap
ahead with unmatched visual Fidelity and
authenticity
Forza Motorsport is back and it's our
most comprehensive game ever with over
500 cars and 20 environments with more
new race cars than ever before
you can experience all of this in our
incredible new online racing mode and in
our all-new car building focused single
player career
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on this incredible game
[Music]
foreign
yep that's me and you're probably
wondering how I ended up here well it's
pretty standard
[Music]
check this out
music player in my chest it's powering
up my new robot arm
it's making everything sync up with the
beat
let's rock
this is awesome
[Music]
that's the defect
what in the hell am I looking at the
name's chai not defect is this the guy
take down this company one boss at a
time
so you know they're insane
profession rock star
hmm
future Rockstar
I'm Shinji mikami Studio head at the
time gamingwalks thank you for all your
support over the years and I'm John
Johannes director on hi-fi Rush
um
[Music]
[Applause]
so everyone thinks of us as putting out
horror games like The Evil Within or
spooky games like ghostwire Tokyo but
this is clearly something totally
different and if this game hasn't
already leaked fingers crossed we hope
it's a pleasant surprise
let's have some fun
um
so
we've been waiting for this for a long
time so let's jump in and explain
exactly what Hi-Fi Rush is
high five Rush is a rhythm action game
so it's a bit of a Twist on your
traditional action game here your moves
and attacks help create a living
soundtrack that means all your flashy
moves stylish and devastating combos add
a layer to the music
the more you flow with the beat the
better you can connect your attacks and
abilities
you are in total control during combat
but everything you do syncs up like an
awesome music video
That's HiFi rush
you play as chai I Wanna Be rock star
and victim of a weird corporate
experiment that lets him sense the
rhythm of the entire world pulsing to
the game soundtrack
[Music]
[Applause]
as you can see the beat moves the world
around you and is the key to combat you
looking for me your attacks will
automatically sink to land on the beat
making Hi-Fi Rush a super easy game to
start playing
however attacking on the beat leads to
combos that end with a musical countdown
we call a beat kick think of big cymbal
crash at the end of the drum Zone like
this
Landing beat hits on the Chicago finish
that adds unique musical Flair and high
damage attacks
and The Crowd Goes Wild
child
oh
um
anyone see the guy that did this
[Music]
how about we see it all in action
Bring It On
[Music]
you're never restrained by the music you
can jump Dodge parry and attack whenever
you want using whatever attacks you want
it's not about mashing buttons the key
here is feeling the beat
[Applause]
[Music]
your progress isn't blocked by missing
the beat but you get rewarded musically
and mechanically for staying in rhythm
foreign
dangerous obstacles
you name it it all sinks to the music
creating an ongoing jam session of a
game
[Music]
your robot cat can
for shoulder and helps you find that
rhythm
but we also have visual guides to help
you even more
[Music]
we want you to be able to enjoy Hi-Fi
Rush whether you're Rhythm Pro or not
that looks so cool doing this
chai also gets by With a Little Help
from his friends
literally
get up slacker we've
we've Tri will team up likely allies who
expand his repertoire of moves both in
and out of combat there's peppermint
breaking barriers and juggling enemies
along with macarons smashing enemy armor
and knocking back at him
tag teaming with chai's partners and
attacks opens up huge possibilities for
dynamic Combos and over-the-top action
[Applause]
that's not bad
the extra help is handy because when
you're not fighting you're going to be
running around and wreaking havoc call
over van delay's corporate headquarters
where everything is trying to take you
down you and your partners have a
singular goal in mind
taking down the bosses of vandelay
Technologies
besides wanting to race chai for being a
defect it seems they've got something a
little bit more Sinister on their
corporate agenda
you'll fight through each department to
take them all on each level with their
own musical spin on the Rock genre and
then we have a showdown
[Music]
let's get ready to crumble boss battles
are climactic set pieces varying from
straight up fights in musical minigames
to chase sequences
custom queries react to licensed music
from amazing artists
high five Rush is like nothing we've
made at Tango before
and we think it's like nothing you've
ever played before either
it's a high energy feel good Rhythm
action experience that's amazingly
satisfying to play
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty rock star move chai
[Applause]
[Music]
motion is
foreign
[Music]
for you to play this we're happy to tell
you that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
not a demo the full game
seriously
it launches on Xbox and PC a few hours
after the show and yes it'll be on Game
Pass as well
we hope you enjoy playing Nick
you looking for me
here
mind if I join
does that mean I have to fight I believe
it does sir
how about
this is entertaining you're going out
with the trash
here's your project Armstrong pass
and welcome to vandelay campus
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Hunt Valley Maryland and the
headquarters of zenimax online Studios
you just saw a cinematic teaser for The
Elder Scrolls online's next chapter I'm
pleased to reveal ESO necron which will
launch in June and is shaping up to be
one of the best updates to the game ever
if you watch the teaser closely you saw
that necron will include one of the most
requested features in ESO a new playable
class called The Arcanist it's only our
third new class since launch and we know
you're gonna love it the arcanus wields
magic influenced by Forbidden Knowledge
and has unique abilities never before
seen in this world
of course the experience of exploring a
new area of Tamriel was the heart of
every ESO chapter necron will unfold an
Eastern Morrowind not seen in an Elder
Scrolls game since 1994 where you will
meet new characters and enemies reunite
with some old friends and explore a
story based around the return of a
well-known Daedric prince you just might
remember from the Dragonborn Skyrim DLC
for those of you new to ESO we release a
new expansion called a chapter every
year chapters are essentially Standalone
games in ESO that let you Adventure in a
new region of Tamriel but you don't have
to wait for the necron chapter to jump
in we've got so many amazing experiences
you can enjoy right now
if you love games like Skyrim and
Oblivion you'll feel right at home
amongst the thousands of stories
unfolding across every region in ESO
and as anyone who's played a classic
Elder Scrolls game knows
it's all about those feelings when
you're fully immersed in the world
[Music]
that feeling when you
are questioned if you are capable of
taking down a frost troll in Skyrim try
it for yourself and ESO
what about the moment you visited a city
in Morrowind that was built inside the
shell of a giant crab
for the Oblivion fans out there how
about another chance at taking on the
Colossal Daedric prince merun's Dagon
just like any single player Elder
Scrolls game you can have a blast simply
by following the main quest line
or seek out lore and learn more about
the world
I'm a Craftsman
go fishing
decorate and furnish your home
customize your character
play it like an action RPG
and when you're ready you can easily
engage in one of the best open world PVP
systems run dungeons co-op with your
friends for great loot
or just join a guild to chat with others
possibilities in this virtual world are
endless
new players will immediately feel right
at home because our community is one of
the most if not the most welcoming on
the planet
we invite everyone who has not yet
experienced ESO to give it a try and
create your own stories in our shared
world there's no required subscription
and thousands of hours of content to dig
into Solo
or with friends
explore nearly every corner of tamrio
with no level restrictions it's magical
being able to travel almost anywhere you
please from the moment you enter the
world
ESO is available on PC and Mac in
addition to previous and current gen
consoles including a purpose-built
next-gen version for the Xbox series xns
with High Fidelity graphics and enhanced
performance modes an added bonus for
Xbox players it's on Game Pass
[Music]
starting today for a limited time we're
making all past chapters available to
explore for any player so everyone can
test drive all of our adventures
including our take on Skyrim Morrowind
Oblivion and much much more
at zos we have so many passionate and
talented developers who continue to add
to Elder Scrolls lore by producing
handcrafted Epic Adventures and I'm
immensely proud to be a part of it
believe me we have tons more to share
and I can't wait for the team to show it
all to you join us after this show for
the 2023 ESO Global reveal where we'll
go deep into all things necron
thanks see you in Tamriel
[Music]
yeah
something evil is swallowing up this
place bit by bit
nobody ever believes things can get this
bad until it happens
man it's too late but
there are people who can fight back
stick together
welcome to redfall Massachusetts where
the calm seas and sunny skies have been
eclipsed by a legion of vampires
[Music]
redfall is a story driven shooter at its
heart which can be played single player
or co-op with up to four players
who's your hero each with their own
unique abilities and form the perfect
vampire slaying Squad to take back red
Falls haunted streets
at Arcane we make games where the world
itself is as important as the characters
with redfall we take an exciting step
forward building a lovingly detailed
open world to deliver our largest
setting ever
inch of our open world is carefully
handcrafted and packed with
environmental storytelling
explore the streets of a quaint Island
Town
from the once bustling downtown to the
haunted forest to the decimated seaside
boardwalk and gorgeously detailed
landmarks
but it's not all danger all the time
there are safe places on the island
where you can rest up chat with
survivors and resupply
[Music]
here we're at the fire station one of
your home bases
this is one place you'll receive
missions from survivors
something I need you to do the Old
Lighthouse in the bay it's been used for
over a century to keep boats away from
the coastline
if we turn it back on it's a warning to
anyone trying to come to redfall right
now easy right
well the Lighthouse Keeper is a real
joined up with those cultists
and took the damn lamp with him
here's a vampire known as the Shroud
shrouds flank at the area in darkness
disorienting their prey
they hurl lethal projectiles and can
even shift through the floor to avoid
damage
[Music]
forever
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the lighthouse is back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire Gods who
will summon the Rook to take you down
foreign
let's transition to what you'll find
outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you redfall
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery that's
Fallen under cultist control save the
locals from being offered to the
vampires
like our past games you can approach a
mission in many different ways
always be ready to improvise
Remy uses her combat robot reborn to
help distract and eliminate the cultists
foreign
thank you
exploring redfall will take you beyond
the bounds of reality as you investigate
otherworldly psychic spaces to unravel
the vampire secrets take this vampire
Nest these deadly layers change each
time you step inside
Jacob sends out his Raven to tag the
enemies below Dev follows up with his
teleporter instantly closing the gap
foreign
to destroy a nest you have to take out
its heart and all of the vampires
willing to die to protect it
horrible way to die
what just happened now Escape The Nest
before it comes crashing down it'll
collapse any second
nests aren't the only psychic spaces
you'll find dangerous pockets all over
the island it's all vampire Turf so
tread carefully
[Applause]
Pitfall won't truly be safe until the
vampires are wiped from the map outside
the main story another one of your
missions is to take back redfall
neighborhood by neighborhood
find safe houses hidden all over the
island and then work your way up to the
vampire controlling the neighborhood
to reclaim this neighborhood you'll have
to defeat a powerful vampire called the
siphon
whether you dive in Solo or with friends
each hero can take on any situation each
brings powerful unique abilities to the
fight and the upgrades you choose change
how they play
here Layla's lift ability can be
upgraded to launch teammates for
Airborne attacks upgrade Layla's
umbrella ability with bullet hail to
absorb enemy bullets and release the
energy back at them
there are many ways to customize your
hero's ability tree to match your play
style
let's get some light on the subject
let's hit on the Arsenal there's a wide
range of Weaponry for military gear to
new vampire slaying inventions from
shotguns to sniper rifles
well well
and of course there's also vampire
Stakes find these in the world to
customize your weapons
[Music]
when you reclaim significant sections of
redfall the last step is to face the
underboss who controls or used to
control that neighborhood
underbosses are powerful Elites of the
vampire Gods with their own unique
abilities like this one's Shield
when you prove yourself against the
underboss you'll receive a key of sorts
a skull that gets you one step closer to
facing the ultimate threat the vampire
gods
thank you for visiting redfall and thank
you for all the support you've shown
Arcane throughout the years we sometimes
joke that our games can be tough to
define the one thing that's consistent
we make the kinds of games we love to
play and that's how redfall was born we
Blended everything we love here at
Arcane Austin immersive open worlds
unique and customizable heroes RPG and
FPS gameplay and of course our signature
storytelling and Rich World building
along with our spin on one of the most
classic monsters of all time vampires
it's been amazing to see how all of us
have pulled together to deliver our
vision for something new redfall is the
biggest most ambitious game we have ever
made our teams Dove head first into this
new opportunity and we can't wait for
you to experience redfall for yourself
thankfully you won't have to wait too
much longer red Falls coming on May 2nd
thank you again for joining us
soon in redfall
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
there we go
three two one
uh
hello it's so much fun to be working
with moyang Studios on Minecraft Legends
this is our best sounding Fortune
Motorsport ever
yeah that was all right
[Music]
thanks and see you in Tamriel
all right let's do this
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Quincy's Tavern my name is
Quincy and I have the privilege and
honor of providing tonight's meal while
we patiently await with a 2023 ESO
Global reveal I hope you're hungry
because tonight you have a special treat
for you I was thinking we would do
something slightly rustic yet filling
but also with a more refined
presentation for the veteran Adventurer
such as yourself hmm
I had ingredients from all across
Tamriel gratin for tonight's special
occasion and I'm so excited to spend
some of this evening with you tonight
we do have a few moments before the
global reveal officially starts so how
about a snack I have just the thing
cabbage biscuits with these bits of
bacon all throughout perfect with some
butter and jam so nice sound good
it's wonderful let me show you how to
make them
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
traveler fresh from the oven careful
they're still very hot but I think with
that we have everything we need for the
eso Global reveal
now go get us some drinks you don't go
nowhere eat to your heart's content
thank you for joining us tonight on this
epic adventure enjoy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the Elder Scrolls Online 2023
Global reveal whether you're coming from
our developer direct or just joining us
now we've got an incredible show today
earlier today Cinemax online Studio
director Matt fire shared some exciting
details on the Elder Scrolls online's
next adventure that includes one of the
most requested features from the eso
Community a new playable class called
The Arcanist Matt also revealed that the
new chapter called necron will take you
back to a familiar location in Tamriel
Morrowind and while there you'll run
into a familiar face a well-known
Daedric prince from the Skyrim
Dragonborn DLC that's just a taste of
what's to come we've got a lot of ground
to cover so let's get started once again
it's my great pleasure to introduce the
Elder Scrolls online's creative director
and my friend Rich Lambert
hey Rich hi Pete good to see you here
yeah it's so great to be back to talk
with you about all the new fun things
the team's been working so hard on I
can't wait to share it with you all all
right it's time to talk necron are you
excited I'm thrilled for this year we're
going to be exploring a new story and
theme centered around the dark elves and
Emmaus Mora the best way to describe
this story is Shadow over Morrowind but
before I go into any more detail we've
got a great way to introduce you to the
mood and feel of this Arc it's Elder
Scrolls
means Cosmic horror and I can't wait for
you all to see it no they don't have to
wait any longer this is the Elder
Scrolls Online necron
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
that was awesome those mushroom Towers
really take me back and some powerful
moments in there but let's start with
breaking down the story in necron
everything centers around Hamas Mora
we've explored small pieces of who this
Prince is in a few zones in ESL to this
point but there are complicated Daedric
prince Maura is the knower of unknown
and horde's knowledge and secrets in
their room some of these secrets are
just too dangerous for any being to know
there are hidden powers that threaten
more as realm of Apocrypha with the
ultimate goal of uncovering one of these
secrets a secret so important and so
dangerous that if discovered it can
unravel all of reality this isn't just
Tamriel that's in trouble this is all of
nerd yes absolutely so where do our
players fit into the mix players are
essentially being tested by Mora to see
if they are worthy to help read them so
over the course of this adventure
players will become sort of a protector
of this ultimate secret that these
hidden powers are searching for there's
also an opportunity for players to seek
out other knowledge if they wish
to dig into some of the origins of our
new playable class in The Arcanist cool
new playable class I am so in and I know
a lot of our players are as well now
we're heading back to Morrowind this
year but it's not the Morrowind that
everyone knows from the Elder Scrolls 3
or even from the 2017 chapter of eso so
it's going to be familiar different a
little bit of both yes sir we're going
to be exploring the Eastern portion of
Morrowind specifically the talvani
peninsula
still home to the Delmar of the Dark
Elves so you're going to see that
familiar alien landscape with the giant
mushrooms and all the like but it's got
a very different feel than any of the
locations that we've previously explored
and I'm guessing the city we saw that
was necron yes yep and we haven't seen
that since the Elder Scrolls Arena and
it looks very different now yeah a lot
has changed since then but yeah necron
is the main city in the chapter and
there's so much amazing lore around this
it's a city of the Dead where Dunmore
families from all over Morrowind bury
their deceased in these elaborate
ceremonies but there's also some really
just wild rumors as to the origins of
necron it's a crazy old city but I'll
leave that up to CJ to kind of dig into
in just a little bit now finally necron
isn't the only cool location that
players are going to get to explore so
tell us us about the zone that I'm
pretty familiar with and some of our
players will be too and that's Apocrypha
yes the Oblivion realm home to Forbidden
Knowledge also home to the know-it-all
Daedric prince that we just saw Hermes
Mora it's always great to revisit other
areas of Tamriel that we haven't seen in
an Elder Scrolls game but I know the
folks at sauce like to build everything
from scratch so when it comes to the
prince's realm it's not just like a
carbon copy of what we've seen before
right the Apocrypha that you know and
love from Skyrim is is it's definitely
there the dark Inky Waters the Towering
stacks of books you know those unique
yellow green Skies but like always we
love being able to explore new areas I
love putting our own spin on things and
we want to make this our own and give
the Players new fun things to explore
and learn it's so exciting sounds like a
great blend of the old and the new when
it comes to like the biomes and the
places the players are going to be
exploring in in necron and in fact let's
Explore More of necron right now with
more details from the team
for the regions in Morrowind and
Apocrypha that have been explored in
previous Elder Scrolls games we approach
them carefully making sure on one side
it felt like a trip down memory lane but
also providing new experiences for
everyone our destination this time was
the telvani peninsula an area we visited
in the very first Elder Scrolls game
arena we also caught a glimpse of its
Coastline in test 3 Morrowind this is
the first time any game has returned to
these lands in almost 30 years and we
were really excited to bring them back
giant mushrooms and distinctive fungus
covered telvani towers are back of
course
East Asian influences at work and some
of the architecture and general
Aesthetics also return as does the alien
landscape so crucial to representing the
lands around bardenfell
for many players Morrowind was their
first introduction to an open world RPG
and this concept was reflected in the
expansive environments of test 3. ESO
has always honored this basic idea the
idea of a world right for wandering and
our depiction of the tavani coast will
reflect this
a sense of odd scale you may feel
walking through it are Paramount
in terms of differences we've crafted a
modern view of the city of necron not
seen since 1994.
getting to work on something Elvish
which predates the tribunal is
particularly interesting
necrom is the dunmer city of the Dead
where all prominent Dark Elves gather to
pay respects and lay to rest their honor
Departed
Lord vivec known as The Warrior poet
spuns some wild stories about the city's
foundations which may or may not be true
but what's definitely true is that the
dark elves have a particular reverence
for the city and its solemn purpose in
their culture
it's naturally a cool thing to be able
to contribute in any significant way to
a long-standing piece of Elder Scrolls
lore
for the tovani coast we had a lot of fun
playing with the legend of necron's
foundation specifically the lore of
vivec himself having defeated the great
beasts golgum or Jill whose bones
supposedly lay the foundations for the
city
entering necron for the first time
you're bound to notice the Towering
rib-like rock formations which enveloped
the city
the dunmer have even added some runic
symbols on the faces of the Rocks
themselves in recognition of their
supposed Origins
is the legend true or simply apocryphal
come tour the lands and make your own
decision on that one necron is intended
to be Monumental reverent and yet fit in
with the shapes and forms we're used to
seeing in dark elf architecture the
distinct Arch doorways and decorative
elements are there as well as the
detailed mosaics on the opulent interior
spaces
we specifically took a lot of
inspiration from the classic telvani
buildings in Morrowind and finally we
have Apocrypha whenever we venture back
into territories from previous Elder
Scrolls games we always try to make sure
that our players feel like they're
genuinely returning to lands they've
traveled before
we took our initial visual cues from the
Skyrim Dragonborn DLC
then we expanded on the ideas presented
in the original
we'll be sharing more details on the
unexplored areas of Apocrypha later this
year
for the meantime let's talk about the
parts that players are a little more
familiar with
some lands in Tamriel appear quite
normal to wear mortal eyes and some like
the tovani coast feel foreign and then
there are the Oblivion planes whose
lands Bend our mortal perceptions into
the most alien landscape possible
in crafting the plane of Apocrypha it
was important to remember that Hermes
Mora doesn't really adhere to
traditional ideas of good or evil as
many other Daedric princes do likewise
Hermes Mora's realm isn't a
representation of good or evil either
our take here was to explore the idea of
ancient records and how they might be
represented physically in a plane such
as this we created fossilized
Impressions into the rock walls and
emerging from the ground representing
the cataloging of all life experience
and knowledge
Realms of Oblivion are extensions of
their master and so Apocrypha is a
Clearinghouse for knowledge it's a
repository it is intended to feel like a
place where ancient things and ancient
ideas can be preserved perhaps even
hidden but never lost
there's a ton of story emitting from
these locations from the environment to
the architecture of course the
characters and creatures breathe even
more life into our world
and the team had a lot of fun bringing
this story to life if you're not super
familiar with any of the Fantasy names
that we've been talking about imagine a
holy necropolis in the middle of an
ancient hierarchical Society presided
over by extremely powerful Mages yeah
there's a lot of fun tensions there for
us to play with
necron remains neutral territory in
regards to the great houses of Morrowind
keeping the City of the Dead neutral
means all dark elves can piece their
ancestors and ensure their bodies are
taken care of even as the three banners
War rages on
this is incredibly important since the
tradition of bringing the dead to necron
predates the tribunal and the creation
of dark elves as we know them it's an
integral part of the dark elf's cultural
identity
in other words this is an ancient city
of the Dead which isn't controlled by
any one dark elf house even though it's
surrounded by the telvani magisters some
of the most egotistical and Powerful
Mages in the entirety of Tamriel
but the peninsula isn't the only place
you'll get to explore as a writer and
certified Library nerd I'm so excited
that this year we get to take you to
Apocrypha for the first time since the
Dragonborn DLC
you'll be accompanied by larimel dewise
a powerful Mage who works with Hermes
Mora the prince of forbidden knowledge
notice I said with and not for larimel
doesn't worship Hermes Mora they have a
working relationship that's built on
mutual respect as much respect as Hermes
Moore can have for Immortal see Mortals
don't really survive an Apocrypha for a
long time knowledge is enticing but
you'd be a fool to assume that it's
harmless and the sheer amount of
information there tends to melt mortal
Minds mangle their bones contort their
flesh and turn them into terrifying
creatures called the hushed
some books are lifeless collections of
paper totally safe to pick up but others
house Tome shells a small danger who
live between the pages of apocrypha's
first editions
they may not necessarily attack you but
if you've ever picked up a shell on the
beach only to discover that there was a
hermit crab already living in it then
you know just how surprising a Tome show
can be
tone shells and hushed aren't the only
denizens in Apocrypha now apocrypha's
Guardians look around every corner
Seekers attend to the vast Library while
lurkers wait beneath the inky Waters to
dissuade any stubborn researchers from
discovering apocrypha's more dangerous
Secrets it's best to be sure that you're
really alone before you pick up some
light reading you'll even meet a clan
list Remora called torvisard who refuses
to let the secrets of Apocrypha remain
undisturbed turfstart's motives are his
mysterious and complexes as allegiances
it's really hard to tell if he's Friend
or Foe
this chapter isn't all about exploring
Crypts and making friends with elder
chores there's a dark threat coming for
both Apocrypha and nirn
vampire mercenaries known as The Dusk
Sabers prowl the talvani peninsula
working for Magister shelranibaro
shelrani seeks to climb the ranks of her
house by any means necessary even
working with anyone who will give her
the power to achieve her goals
not everything will be hidden and
mysterious though if you've played ESO
before there are a bunch of familiar
faces for you to find throughout this
chapter
I won't spoil all of the surprises but
we are bringing back my favorite morik
Tong assassin Asher okay yes scenario
will make an appearance too
with all this focus on secrecy and
Forbidden Knowledge it'll be up to you
to discover the truth and stop enemies
across Eastern Morrowind and apocrypha
good luck
hey everyone we're excited to let you
all know that the Elder Scrolls Online
necron is available for pre-purchase
right now while the chapter will launch
on PC Mac and consoles this June we've
got plenty of reasons for you to
pre-purchase and jump into ESO today if
you're a new player someone who hasn't
played ESO in a while or you still need
to pick up some of our previous chapters
you'll want to go with the necron
collection either version the standard
or the deluxe collection grants you
instant access to six of our previous
chapters and the base game and you'll of
course be able to access the necron
chapter once it launches in June that's
hundreds of hours of content all in one
package we like to refer to it as eight
games in one since each is like its own
Standalone Elder Scrolls adventure and
keep in mind you can play these in any
order too for current players we're
offering both standard and Deluxe
upgrades which will provide you with the
latest necron chapter
no matter what version you pre-purchase
you'll receive these items while some
will be unlocked at launch everyone will
receive this unique Mount immediately
for a limited time if you pre-purchase
necron you'll also receive this matching
pet to go along with the amount that
Jess just mentioned
coming with the deluxe edition is this
new Apocrypha theme one of a kind mount
that's in addition to other pre-purchase
items that come with the deluxe upgrade
and collection
separate from our pre-purchase offering
but just as cool is the Hermes Mora
collector statue that's available for
pre-order at the Bethesda gear store be
sure and secure yours along with some
awesome ESO merch because right now for
a limited time we have a flash sale
running
any addition of necron also unlocks the
new Arcanist class at launch and we know
you've been eagerly awaiting more
information on that so let's check it
out now
all right we've waited long enough Rich
it's Arcanist time spill some details
where do you want to start you know this
is easily been the number one most
requested feature from players since the
Necromancer back in 2019 or elsewhere
well I mean why don't we give the
players a little bit of the back story
and inspiration behind The Arcanist The
Arcanist is a new way to play and
experience ESO it's the seventh playable
class and channels the power of
Apocrypha to create ancient rooms of
power
this weird knowledge lets them do some
truly fantastic things destroying their
enemies with ruining magic summoning
Tentacles from the abyss healing their
allies and some even protecting
themselves from the worst the Daedric
planes have to offer of course what
everyone really wants to know is how do
you play The Arcanist and we've got just
the person to tell us
with The Arcanist we want to keep the
basic form of the class familiar to
everyone so there's something for all
play Styles while letting us be more
creative with the abilities themselves
we started off with three skill lines
Harold watone
apocalypse Soldier and Curative Rune
forms
each line focuses on a different aspect
of the game offense defense and support
challenge we embraced was making these
abilities feel unique compared to
previous classes but not so
systematically different that veteran
players would feel out of place
I know several of the abilities will
leave you awestruck two of my favorite
new abilities are apocryphal gate and
Abyssal impact apocryphal gate lets you
open a pair of temporary portals you can
jump between for extra in-fight Mobility
or use these portals for Creative
exploration
Abyssal impact is a bit more direct it
has you infuse your arm with unstable
energy transforming it into a tentacular
weapon as you thrust forward damaging
and debilitating your foes I'm also
super excited to share that we're doing
something very different for The
Arcanist implementing a combo point
system in this system certain abilities
will build points while you should spend
them giving them an extra bit of oomph
by enhancing or augmenting the ability
dreaming for this to be something that
all players can easily get a handle on
so no one should worry that this class
will be too technical to play can't let
too much out of the bag yet though so
the rest will have to be a secret for
now we're initially coming up with The
Arcanist we had a ton of ideas and
inspiration coming from all sorts of
places movies Comics classic literature
and both retro and modern games
it was even a handful of anime
references
and while we had a lot of great ideas
there was one that led us to a major
breakthrough and helped bind everything
together the Black Books of Hermes Mora
now while this gave us a solid feel for
how the ability should look and sound
you won't necessarily be building one of
the Black Books
instead you'll summon your own tone in
which you've inscribed numerous bits of
ancient knowledge that you've gleaned
from the prince of fate
a bit like your own cookbook you glance
at every so often to spice up your
spouse this won't be the only Taste of
the darkness you'll get though you also
come across foes and maybe a friend who
will wield the same deep magic that
you'll learn but there may even be some
unforeseen enemies that have Combs worth
of forbidden Arcane power to throw at
you this is just the first page of the
story of this new class we've had a ton
of fun making it and we've got plenty
more to show you as time goes on can't
wait for you all to experience
adventuring Tamriel and the Realms
Beyond alongside or as an Arcanist
okay rich now let's talk about some new
features and systems start with any
chance there's going to be some new
companions yes in fact we've got two new
companions coming to ESO with this
necron chapter and for those that don't
know who or what companions are they're
your permanent adventuring police
someone that's at your beck and call
whenever you want to help you explore
Tamriel and the feedback from players
since the Inception back in 2021 has
been overwhelmingly positive and we've
been looking to expand and evolve it in
new ways so tell us about the two new
companions we're going to see the first
companion is called sharpest Knight and
he is an Argonian Warden who is a bit of
a mercenary and an enigma he originated
from black Marsh but his past is lost to
him and he spent a lot of time trying to
figure out who he is to no avail he is a
lot more reserved than our other
companions as he's lived a tough life
and he really isn't overly chatty and
you're are going to have to prove
yourself to them
and then there is a Xander asander is a
red guard male and a little bit of a
crazy fatherly figure Professor I think
Willy Wonka means Dumbledore and he's
got this really singular focus on the
pursuit of knowledge and so what's so
special about isander rich as some of
you might have guessed with Xander being
so focused on this pursuit of knowledge
he's an archist himself so you'll be
able to dig into a bit on that side of
his story as well some amazing stuff and
that's not all we've got cooking like
every chapter we offer loads of side
quests and new trial there's world
events public Dungeons delves and more
really how much content do you think
we're talking here Rich players can
expect around 30 hours of content just
from the main storyline in addition to
all the side content and everything you
just mentioned
always so much to do in an Elder Scrolls
chapter and the team has really pulled
out all the stops with necron we really
have and players won't have to wait too
long to begin their Shadow over
Morrowind Adventure players will be able
to begin their Adventures this march
with our first DLC
awesome I will definitely be checking
that out before we wrap things up let's
talk about some changes that you're
planning to the eso calendar absolutely
so ESO is a living breathing world that
is constantly evolving as a team we're
always evaluating where we are what the
game needs and the community sentiment
around how well we're doing
over the years we have made many changes
based on these evaluations but one of
the fundamental pillars that hasn't
changed is always been to create as much
story content as we possibly can
to try to keep up with our players and
their insatiable desire for new stories
and Adventures
and this constant Drive is one of the
reasons why ESO has become one of the
best games on the market today there's
so much to do so many stories and
locations to experience tons of systems
and various activities to participate in
Solo or with friends so what's changing
we want to continue on creating these
new adventures while also addressing
quality of life feedback and and bugs
that have emerged over time in other
words we want to focus on polish and
iterate more on cool ideas be it stories
or systems with the overall goal of
making each release as solid as it can
be the first half of the Year isn't
really going to change much we've been
hard at work on a lot of this stuff for
a very long time we're still doing a
dungeon DLC with two new Dungeons and a
prologue quest to kick off this new arc
the chapter is releasing in June with
all the goodies you love and expect
where things are changing this year are
fall and winter it's great news for
players don't stop keep going late
summer our focus is going to be on bugs
and quality life additions things like
pre-made group finder or an all-in-one
attunable set crafting station as
examples
there won't be any dungeons in this
update because for update 40 which comes
towards the end of the year the team is
working on something really epic
something pretty special that they just
need more time on I mean come on Rich we
got to give them more than that okay
fine how does
an endless dungeon with a buddy sound oh
sounds good we'll have a lot more info
on this later in this year but I'm
insanely excited about it sounds very
cool well rich I want to thank you for
all the details surrounding necron and
the shadow over Morrowind Adventure
today I know I'm excited to play and I
sure hope everyone watching is as well
we are just as excited but before I go I
wanted to personally thank the entire
team for all of their incredible work
truly an honor to be able to represent
them here today also on behalf of the
entire zos team around the globe I'd
like to thank you all for your continued
support you've helped make ESO and its
amazing Community what it is today
all right let's throw it back to Jess
and Gina to fill everyone in on in-game
events talk guilds and more
so it's obviously no secret that there's
always something to do in ESO in
addition to all this content we offer a
wide variety of in-game events catering
to all different play styles from PvP to
Overland seasonal festivities and More
in addition to our quarterly content
Updates this year we'll be having 11
in-game events plus the themed monthly
PVP Battleground weekends in fact our
first in-game event for the year the
season of the Dragon celebration starts
in just a couple days
and who better to enjoy all these events
with than friends ESO is great solo but
even better with friends or a whole
Guild of friends whether you're into PVP
12 player trials crafting questing or
even fishing and house decorating there
is a guild or five for everyone and
every play style you can find your first
or next Guild via the in-game guild
finder if you're a current player and
have a guild who is looking to welcome
new adventures let us know about it on
Twitter tag us at test online and
speaking of coming together we're
extremely excited to let everyone know
that we'll be hosting an in-person event
this spring to celebrate All Things ESO
and the shadow over Morrowind Adventure
we'll share details on our website and
social channels very soon in the
meantime if you want to learn more about
the first DLC in the shadow over
Morrowind Adventure we'll be previewing
the DLC and update 37 live on Twitch
this Friday
so be sure and tune in
lots of change lots of new
quick reminder that ESO necron is
available for pre-purchase right now
visit elder scrollsonline.com or your
favorite online retailer and claim your
Mount and pet today
ESO necron launches this tune and
believe it or not we're just getting
started stay tuned in the months leading
up to launch for even more info thanks
for spending your time with us we'll see
you in Tamriel